[Music]
hello and welcome to drive at the DW car
show on this edition a world premiere in
Barcelona
od unveils its new a8 taking the plunge
the MP car 770 plus the new e-class
convertible from Mercedes
[Music]
the new e-class convertible rounds off
mercedes-benz e-class range it's the
fifth member of the family alongside the
sedan the station wagon the coupe a and
all terrain models and it could look
back in a very successful history dad a
300 C e24 from 1992 was mercedes-benz
first four-seater convertible explains
our car man Emmanuelle and even back
then it boasted some rather special
safety features like the automatically
deployed robot the new model has it too
many other things
hi [ __ ] male among the standard
features are a driver fatigue attention
assist an active brake assist and the
pre-safe system familiar from other
models which can prevent accidents by
identifying critical handling situations
plus multi-beam LED headlights ensure
the road ahead is always clearly visible
after dark the designers also set out to
increase pedestrian safety in case of a
head-on collision and certain
circumstances the rear section of the
hood can be lifted up the increased
clearance from the components in the
engine compartment creates additional
deformation space to reduce the risk of
injury to pedestrians
the LED tail lights featuring a new
crystal treatment are likewise standard
the optional comfort package creates an
in-car Indian summer thanks to the air
scarf neck level heating and the air cap
feature which cuts down air turbulence
we checked out the e 400 convertible
with a 245 kilowatt engine the interior
shows the usual high quality workmanship
and equipment it's replete with leather
and high gloss finishes and there's a
range of extras to make driving more
enjoyable there's a heated steering
wheel and for the front seats a memory
function and ventilation to keep you
cool when the weather's hot there's
something for everyone here the standard
fitted acoustic soft top which minimizes
noise and enhances climate comfort opens
and closes in 20 seconds
[Music]
and that also applies when you're on the
road of course up to a speed of 50 km/h
as every convertible driver knows
explains him on well when the car has
been parked in the Sun for a few hours
leather seats can be pretty
uncomfortable especially if you're
wearing shorts so Mercedes came up with
heat reflecting leather it keeps the
temperature reasonable so when the car
has been standing in the Sun you're not
likely to burn your legs the e-class
convertible offers a range of five
gasoline and diesel engines with the Eco
start/stop function the three liter
6-cylinder unit we had propelled our
test car from zero to 100 km/h in 5.5
seconds top speed is 250 emanuelle finds
the engine output range from 143 to 245
kilowatts pretty impressive even the
smallest unit packs a punch
plus the 9g tronic automatic
transmission is standard for all and all
wheel drive is also optionally available
and the new model is big the convertible
is 12 centimeters longer 7 centimetres
wider and has an 11 centimeter longer
wheelbase than its predecessor overall
Amano says the new e-class convertible
is a perfect open top four seater the
simple reason is there is no real
competition in this segment and this is
no 1 of the 4 seater this is the unique
article as rear seat passengers will
discover two
[Music]
[Applause]
prices started just over 54,000 euros in
Germany with the e 400 we tested costing
70 thousand euros plus car makers are
always conjuring up new ways of
presenting their products welcome to the
inaugural edition of the Audi summit
where the Bavarian showcase the
innovations they hope will make them a
premium digital car company at trade
fairs today says sales and marketing
chief deep mouthful tonight new products
are just a mouse-click away you can
present a car at the fair and post the
complete presentation online trade fairs
no longer have quite the same status so
we thought it would be a good idea to
make a strong branding statement now and
again and that Audi summit was born it
was an explosive showcase of the Audi
range if you've got it flaunt it
the huge mainstage played host to an
extravaganza of dance acrobatics and
automotive ballet the highlight of the
audiovisual spectacular the world
premiere the new flagship a8 now in its
fourth generation over 2,000 guests from
around the world we're in Barcelona to
witness the event welcome to the Future
Premium welcome to the all-new Audi a8
the challenge explains Audi design chief
mark least it was to introduce a new
design theme and it makes sense to start
with a top-of-the-range model you can
see how the a8 has a completely new
exterior look the shoulder line has been
lowered to between the wheels that
created more space for muscles above the
front and rear wheels and that new
design vocabulary makes the a8 highly
distinctive all over the exterior
whether on the sides the rear at the
front the single frame radiator grille
has undergone some radical changes mike
leake this is the single frame now has
significantly different proportions for
the last 10 years it was more vertical
so to visualize the performance
character they made the grille flatter
and wider inside out he wanted to up the
comfort with plenty of space for rear
passengers - and there are some
interesting new features up front
building touch screens that let the
driver operate the a8 in smartphone
style the architecture the dashboard is
all new like no other howdy before it is
smooth now we've integrated the displays
into a piano black finish fleshing to
github and as for what those controls
can do the new a8 is the world's first
production car with advanced autonomous
driving technology and slow moving
traffic on highways it can take control
of the car at speeds of up to 60 km/h
allowing the driver to focus another
another highlight is the active
suspension a front-mounted camera and
laser scanners detect uneven patches of
road in advance and adjust the
suspension accordingly
the electromechanical rotary damper
system responds in milliseconds and
adapts to the road conditions the new
Audi a8 also absorbs the kinetic energy
generated by any bumps or holes ensuring
a very smooth ride
[Music]
and the new luxury sedan is also setting
the pace on the safety front an array of
cameras ultra scan sensors and radar and
laser scanners combined to prevent
collisions the car analyzes the driving
behavior of other vehicles passenger
safety is top priority
the first new a8 models to hit the road
come with a v6 gasoline engine and a v6
diesel they will be followed by eight
and twelve cylinder versions and a
plug-in hybrid
Jaguar has launched its new compact SUV
with a spectacular stunt the e pace
dually leaped into the Guinness Book of
Records with a 270 degree barrel roll
the new crossover comes with a choice of
three diesel and two gasoline engines
it's a step down in size from the F pace
and in price to starting at just under
35,000 euros in Germany Ford is
presenting the new generation of the
Fiesta the iconic supermini celebrated
its 40th birthday last year but it's
looking younger and more progressive
than ever before it will come in seven
equipment lines with a range of
customization options and spring 2018
sees the arrival of the fiestas active a
crossover model featuring higher ground
clearance and protective cladding
[Music]
car tester undelete Zimmerman recalls
Subaru rolling out its very first
rear-wheel drive vehicle in 2012 the
result of a collaboration with Toyota
it was named rather unimaginative li
boxer rear-wheel drive Zenith or BRZ and
now he'd like to find out what makes
this rear wheel drive car with a boxer
engine a Zenith of automotive
achievement the BRZ and the identical GT
86 by Toyota were the first product of
Subaru and Toyotas collaboration Subaru
had taken the initiative and then Toyota
expressed its interest and adding the
sports car to its model range the moment
Andre steps on the gas he realizes the
engine is not the reason for the
confident name especially not in
combination with the automatic
transmission but that's only half the
story under the hood the Toyota
influence is obvious the boxer engine
combines natural aspiration with Toyotas
d-4s direct injection
the Mystics more important to Andre then
the performance of this engine is the
construction type is a boxer engine
that means the crankshaft and the
cylinders are in this case above level
with the tops of the tires but as we
don't have an inline four-cylinder
configuration so the center of gravity
is farther back that allows a near ideal
distribution of weight with a low center
of gravity the BR C's facelift has left
the basic body completely intact
what's new are the full LED headlights
reworked from fasciae and restyled rims
the racy contours accompanied by flared
rear fenders impress sports car fans
from the outset the new rear spoiler now
stands some distance above the trunk lid
the taillights have also been reworked
[Music]
the spring rates for the suspension and
the dampers have been tweaked and the
rear stabilizers reinforced in Andrzej
notices that high centrifugal forces
hardly bothered the BRZ this is where
Subaru shows it's true cornering
qualities the suspension is very
communicative and dynamic the driver
always knows what the front and rear
axles are doing and where there's any
loss of traction so they can respond
instantaneously blitz Noda again our
test car had the sports plus line which
differs from the regular sports edition
only thanks to the Alcantara leather and
heated seats the six-speed automatic
transmission in this car is great at
saving fuel since it tends to rain in
both the acceleration and the top speed
the vrc's tires are the same size as the
ones on the current Toyota Prius so the
BRC might drift a bit rather than
keeping to its lane amateur racing
drivers often replace them with
something that has a bit more traction
notice is how dynamic the Subaru can be
when accelerating out of a curve a
differential lock sensitive to the
torque make sure the thrust goes to the
wheel with the most traction so it's not
wasted the BRZ is a driving machine a
samurai that cuts its way through curves
the engine may not be that powerful but
the car has still become very popular as
a sports coupe a due mainly to its
excellent handling even so most buyers
up for the BRZ twin from Toyota and its
lower price tag
[Music]
venez concept under assure that anyone
who understands the vrc's concept will
agree it's a curved monster of the
highest quality anybody who doesn't like
that would probably rather drive
straight than around bends but andre
still wouldn't call it the zenith the
rear wheel drive boxer engine cars
Porsches had a monopoly claim to that
for decades one last tip don't buy the
automatic buy this stick shift
here to Porsche is years ahead of Subaru
when it comes to rapid-fire
automatic shifting angle front lip
sticks convinced that when it comes to
towing capacity there's just no way
around the Volkswagen Touareg it can
handle up to 3.5 tonnes but he's going
to concentrate on the interior because
this is a special Turek the interior has
some juicy details in store VW had some
new ideas for the Touareg facelift aside
from the new front section the changes
to the exterior are hard to spot
taking center stage among the
innovations are the v6 TDI engines
they've acquired an SCR catalytic
converter module that considerably
reduces nitrogen oxides the driver can
indulge in the torque to cruise along or
put on the power it makes the dash to
100 km/h in 7.3 seconds reaching a top
speed of 225 kilometers per hour
VW has also given its workhorses
taillights a new grooming
cargo capacity begins at 697 liters with
a maximum of 1642 liters the trailer
hitch pops out at the push of a button
[Music]
the Triggs air suspension carries it
across the roughest terrain on top of
the sporty our line design on the
outside our test car had the extensive
executive package of interior features
home Bruni is impressed the nappa
leather seats have the diamond quilted
pattern and decorative stitching Plus
adjustable heating and ventilation the
dash has luxurious woodgrain trim but
one thing that shows the spiffed up
Tuareg is in cutting edge in every
respect is the relatively sluggish
infotainment system the steering tool
feels a bit indirect on the road that
has to do with making it suitable for
off-road maneuvering even so the power
steering makes parking for example a
cinch and physical terms
[Music]
if all we talk Bharani VW Touareg is a
midsize luxury SUV chock full of luxury
features thanks to the air suspension he
can lower the rear at the push of a
button handy for loading heavy objects
it may take a little while but it works
like a charm the Touareg is a great
all-rounder for car buyers with the
necessary financial resources it can
handle rugged terrain heavy loads and
even families out on vacation today our
classy car expert christophe Bauer is
hitting the road in a unique mix of
color and boat it's German engineers
Hans triples legendary MP car as early
as 1932 the self-taught automotive
designer had converted his old dkw race
car into an amphibious vehicle but his
most important creation was the Amphicar
770 produced starting in 1961 it was the
first series production amphibious
vehicle made for private customers hunts
Christoph says banks triple was obsessed
with creating an amphibious car and
devoted his entire life to the idea the
Christoph says The Passion of visionary
did experience some setbacks like in
December 1934 when the car ended up at
the bottom of the Rhine River during a
test-drive
but that very night triple salvaged his
waterlogged vehicle and three days later
it was back on the road through all the
highs and lows he never let anything
distract him from his vision Triple
built his last amphibious car prototype
in 1990 at the age of 81 series
production of the MP car began in 1961
Hannes tipple got financing from German
industrialist habit quant the amphibious
car mainly targeted the US market which
as Christophe notes was evident from his
very name
as neckla Nelson he explains it was
called the 770 because it could go
around seven miles per hour in water and
70 miles per hour on land he thinks the
car is a great idea and should have sold
like hotcakes in the land of opportunity
the amphicars body was made in the
northern German city of Lubeck with the
final assembly being done in Berlin
production of 25,000 EFI cars was
planned but the initial reaction to the
model was less than enthusiastic
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I'm fika Christoph quotes one of
the first damning verdicts the Amphicar
combines the qualities of an impractical
car with those of an impractical
motorboat
he says that's cruel but unfortunately
true he hasn't tried it in water yet but
even on land driving down winding roads
is enough to make you seasick the little
1.1 litre rear-mounted engine from
triumph delivers just 38 horsepower
which doesn't make for much driving
pleasure and back in 1961 the Americans
with their big v8 engines were used to
something else entirely
about a man still the Amphicar is a real
beauty huh okay that was a joke
Christopher he thinks that the designs
overly ambitious though well intended it
looks half-baked he admits there's some
nice chrome trim and of course these
generous tail fins as a nod to us
customers the fins also serve to break
any waves and protect the engine from
getting flooded the amphibious part
these two ships propellers down here
that drive the car in the water the
bottom part of the body is a completely
sealed hole and here in the doors there
are extra rubber seals to keep the water
out at least that was the hope Topsy
couldn't before the Amphicar was
delivered to buyers every single one was
tested in a pool first to make sure it
was watertight still one look at the
Afrikaners standard equipment its water
breaking tail fins raised exhaust pipe
and obligatory paddle doesn't exactly
fill Christoph with confidence
[Music]
ripped-up will it float or won't it
fatzkee wonders now comes the exciting
part here we go it's very important to
insert the navigation light here at the
rear especially when traveling at night
then Christa gets in and battens down
the hatches these little levers on the
doors are to seal everything off
completely it's time to head for the
water once he's in he'll put it in
neutral and engage the propellers using
this stick shift
fair winds and following seas
Oh God he says it's a strange feeling
driving a car into the water it's
floating it's floating christophe simply
can't believe it driving by it's two
ships propellers the Amphicar can
achieve a speed of 6.5 knots or roughly
12 kilometers an hour the propellers
have to be switched off as soon as it's
back on dry land without the counter
pressure of the water they'd rotate far
too fast and cause massive damage to the
separate water transmission
[Music]
Kristof honestly can't understand why
you need a sport boat license to pilot
the Amphicar in Germany because it's
hardly a sporty mode of transport
churning along so casually just turning
it takes a lot of patience because the
steering only functions through the
front wheels and the turning circle is a
whopping 35 metres though salt water
could be corrosive the Amphicar is even
seaworthy in 1962 for Britain's crossed
the English Channel in 2 MP cars that
took them just under 7 and a half hours
getting into the water isn't a problem
but getting out can be the 770 is a
rear-wheel drive model so the front
wheels are of no help when it comes to
navigating steep shorelines
[Music]
Christophe says the vehicles pretty high
maintenance - after five hours in the
water there are a dozen spots that need
greasing and that's not his thing in the
1960s most potential buyers were the
same opinion of the twenty five thousand
vehicles planned just three thousand 878
were actually built and production
ceased altogether in 1968 only a few
Americans bought one but Krista thinks
that's a real shame because as the first
series production amphibious vehicle for
private use
the Amphicar is definitely a milestone
and automotive history and great fun -
at first Christoph laughed at the
Amphicar but in the end he wanted one
himself
no wonder the model is prized by
collectors and commands high prices MP
cars in good shape can change hands for
well over 50,000 euros and next time on
driving the new Audi rs5 coupe a
[Music]
and be afraid be very afraid the
rolls-royce wrath black patch
[Music]